well there are some diseases and
infections that were almost wiped out
two decades ago but a new study shows
these same STDs are making a comeback in
this country and in the Silver State
thanks for joining us here at six I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis the
data is really staggering Nevada seeing
one of the highest spikes in the nation
Victoria Saha looked into the numbers
and what they mean to our city here she
is Victoria
new studies show us that there have been
a 500 percent increase in STDs over the
last 20 years in the country Nevada has
seen the fourth highest increase in the
nation but it's not impo impossible to
combat the issue
there are dozens of different sexually
transmitted diseases and infections out
there but a study by inner body gives us
a breakdown of how many reported cases
of HIV gonorrhea syphilis and chlamydia
there are in Nevada while chlamydia is
the highest there is concern about
syphilis according to family
practitioner Dr Elena Garcia it's one of
the diseases that could be misdiagnosed
you know so it can be very very tricky
in another study by value penguin led by
health insurance expert Nick VanZant he
says nearly 20 years ago syphilis was
close to being eliminated and chlamydia
was easier to detect the numbers are
absolutely a cause for concern so what
happened we're seeing a decline in
sexual education we're seeing a decline
in preventive measures and all of that
has equaled to an increase in STDs the
study by value penguin showed the STD
rates per 100
000 residents in Nevada for the year
2000 jumped from 276 to
857 in 2020. Dr Garcia says there are
new drugs out there to help prevent
certain STDs but they don't work for all
of them it really does come down to
nothing works for everything so that's
why condoms still remain important she
also says since STDs are hard to detect
right away she recommends getting a
blood test every time you get a new
partner
Dr Garcia also recommends getting tested
every year as a precaution and from the
studies I looked at I learned that most
health insurance will cover the cost of
STD testing and treatment like any other
health condition though there may be a
copay Denise